welcome back to cbs saturday morning
another highlight of the super bowl is
the halftime show and sundays will be
something special a celebration of soul
funk and hip-hop with an array of stars
including snoop dogg eminem and mary j
blige but they're not the only
performers getting ready for the big day
joy benedict has the story of some young
musicians hoping to strike a chord with
fans
sofi stadium is almost ready to host the
biggest game in football but the la rams
won't be the only hometown favorite
hoping to harmonize on this field
i think it's great that we get to
be there and show everybody that we can
do something magical for 17 year old
steve corvera something magical involves
the clarinet it just makes me feel like
i'm on another planet he is one of 20
musicians selected to perform with the
youth orchestra of los angeles during
the pregame of the super bowl i'm elated
i'm so grateful to be
doing this opportunity high school
senior rachel keavy is a flautist with a
goal people need to see that the flu is
a versatile instrument
the group is performing with gospel duo
mary mary those selected were chosen
from high school seniors and recent
graduates of yola a program that has
been helping young people fall in love
with music for 15 years it is funded
through the l.a philharmonic providing
instruments and instruction to children
in underserved communities i just think
this program is really good because it
shows that
minorities can be a part of music
especially classical music because we're
like very like under represented and
although their song is just one part of
a day full of entertainment these
students hope their performance will be
the sweet sound that inspires others to
dream big
for cbs saturday morning joy benedict
los angeles
there's like 14 different reasons to
look forward
thank you morgan
and we've we've given you
this morning i think